i want to talk about the three
bellies okay if you look around
and observe people you're going to find
out a lot of people have belly fat but
today we're going to differentiate three
different types of belly fat there are
three different problems and i wrote a
book about this and i talk about the
four different bellies but today we're
going to combine two of those in one and
kind of talk about the actual underlying
causes because that belly type is the
same shape but it's coming from two
different causes and so we have the
sagging belly fat okay
that is either
a problem with
too much insulin or
too much cortisol cortisol is a stress
hormone the next belly is the protruded
belly
you usually see this
with the guy that's wearing the speedo
on the beach he's thin but he has this
basketball
pregnant
stomach okay
that is not fat
it is a liver problem the liver is very
very damaged and this person is leaking
fluid
from the liver into a sac
in the abdomen so it's a fluid-filled
sac if you take one part of the belly
and you tap on the other part you'll
feel there'll be a little bit of a
ripple effect okay so that's number two
now the third belly is more of a lower
pooch
you see this a lot in women but it's
also in men it's more of a superficial
fat it's called subcutaneous fat it's
not necessarily the fat that's around
the organs it's just superficial and a
lot of times it comes from too much
estrogen okay so let's first talk about
the sagging belly
this is called visceral fat visceral fat
is spill off from the liver the liver is
filling up with fluid and it has nowhere
to go so then it spills off around the
organs around the intestines around the
heart around the pancreas
a lot of times the fat goes inside the
organs as well but this is more of a
dangerous fat because it is obstructing
the function of certain organs
especially the pancreas and it is also
releasing certain
things that are increasing your
inflammation which then causes problems
in the heart it causes problems with
insulin resistance it creates problems
in other organs so this type of belly
is usually coming from too much
insulin which is then triggered from too
many carbohydrates that's right i know
you're shocked but too many carbs will
increase insulin and put the fat right
in your gut now just because someone
doesn't have belly fat doesn't mean they
don't have visceral fat there's a term
called tofi
that stands for thin on the outside
fat on the inside so just because
someone doesn't have a gut
doesn't mean they don't have visceral
fat i just wanted to point that out
now i want to mention cortisol for a
second cortisol is a stress hormone
what cortisol does
is it indirectly
increases insulin so when you have a
sagging belly that effect is created by
insulin which is either coming from
carbohydrates
or stress from cortisol
so
the cortisol makes your belly increase
by triggering insulin because cortisol
increases
the production
of glucose from
non-carbohydrate sources so in other
words it'll take your protein it'll take
your fat and turn it into glucose which
then triggers insulin so when you go
through stress
it will increase your blood glucose from
other things
not
carbs so stress and sugar create the
same effect
belly fat and many other problems and
the term for that is called
gluconeogenesis okay the creation of new
sugar now as far as getting rid of this
type of belly do you think exercise
would be a significant thing to focus on
the answer is no
diet you're not going to see much
results with exercise why because
exercise does not decrease insulin in a
significant way the majority of the
results are going to be from
keeping your carbs low from your diet
now exercise will help reduce stress but
it's not going to be a significant
factor now if your problem is stressed
there's a lot of things you can do
i created some videos down below if
you're new to my channel because so many
people are going through stress and i
have some really great tips on that but
i will say as a side note
probably the biggest source of stress
comes from other people so there are
certain personality types that can keep
a person under constant stress and
unless they deal with that man there's
going to be just a difficult time
getting rid of belly fat
and the other point is sleep if you can
fix your sleep you can greatly fix your
stress all right let's shift to the
protruding belly this is a liver problem
usually
cirrhosis
advanced liver disease
and the problem is this has been going
for a long time when you start
generating fluid in your abdomen
your liver is pretty messed up and the
chances of you reversing it
are pretty slim unless you catch it at
some earlier stage
and completely change your lifestyle
things in the future the prognosis is
not very good for this body type i mean
think about it you have the liver that
is so dysfunctional that is leaking
fluid into a sac around your abdomen and
you have to go to the hospital every 14
days to get it drained out not a good
situation now if i was in that situation
and someone were to give me some advice
i would radically 100 percent get on
board and start changing my lifestyle so
it really depends on the person and how
disciplined they are unfortunately a lot
of these cases with the cybes is tied
with alcoholics and they have a very
difficult time giving up alcohol
but number one you're going to have to
figure out what's triggering this and
stop that bad habit vitamin e in the
form of tocotrienols okay is very very
beneficial for
cirrhosis which is fibrosis which is
like scar tissue in your liver and so if
you start taking about
300 milligrams of tocatrinos twice or
three times a day that would be a very
smart thing that can actually reduce the
formation of fibrosis and and maybe even
reverse some of that
the other types of foods that you need
to focus on are foods for the liver that
would be cruciferous vegetables
moderate to low amount of protein not
extremely low but you don't want to go
high protein because liver is damaged
and the person has lost a lot of liver
function to metabolize that protein so
when you overload a damaged liver too
much protein
you don't help the situation all right
the next thing you want to focus on is
your microbiome your microbes and your
gut
actually make
a secondary type of bile salt that can
actually take the pressure off your
liver and help the liver greatly there's
another remedy that i would recommend if
i personally had cirrhosis or
late stage
liver disease
it's called tutcom it's a type of
biosalt that's really really good for
the liver i just would recommend it if i
was trying to
deal with this advanced liver problem
now would exercise help
very very insignificant
effect from exercise you're going to
have to focus mainly on your eating
and avoiding certain things all right so
now let's talk about the superficial fat
the subcutaneous fat which by the way is
not very dangerous a lot of people have
it and exercise would be very very
beneficial
in addition to
cutting your carbs and doing
intermittent fasting i will say though
it does take a long time
to get rid of that last bit of belly fat
but if you increase the amount of
fasting that you do
and you follow these next
recommendations i think you can speed it
up but many times the person is estrogen
dominant okay so we don't want to
increase too much estrogen because
estrogen increases the superficial fat
around the body especially in the hips
the thighs and the buttocks so we want
to lower estrogen how do we do that we
avoid soy products we avoid
things with pesticides herbicides
fungicides and we consume more organic
foods we avoid dairy which by the way
can greatly increase your estrogen we
want to avoid plastics yeah that's right
plastics are in your food the average
person in the u.s consumes the amount of
plastic that equals the size of a credit
card
so i've done a video on that check it
out down below if you haven't seen it
and most of the estrogen in our body
actually comes from
testosterone so there's a certain enzyme
called aromatase that
converts testosterone
to estrogen and when you have too much
of that enzyme you make too much
estrogen and so you can do a natural
aromatase inhibitor
to lessen the production of estrogen and
take a while guess what foods would be
good for that cruciferous vegetables and
then there's a concentrated cruciferous
product called
dim that would be a very good thing to
take as well and lastly omega-3 helps to
inhibit that enzyme lessening the amount
of excess estrogen so there you have it
the three bellies so now what you need
is the exact plan of what to eat i
created that in this very easy to follow
step-by-step
playlist check it out right here
you